[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport le
magazine est toujours consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est parti à pour le sommaire ont joué
ce week-end sur les terrains de rugby
l'union rugby centre s'est incliné ce
dimanche contre le roc j fois sur le
score de 18 à 17 le résumé du match dans
ce magazine jo-2000 24 14 entités yvin
oise ont reçu le label terre de jeux
2024 de la part du comité d'organisation
parmi elles à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
aux roses seront bernard a des bons vice
président en charge des sports pour nous
parler de ce label découverte
aujourd'hui direction dans ce à magazine
l'aider terral sur le terrain de
football notre journaliste grégory canal
et vous fait découvrir sa passion pour
le poste de gardien de but il a pu
tester un entraînement avec l'étoile
sportive de trappes l'actualité du
sportif de la semaine c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence donc par du rugby ont joué
sur les terrains du championnat honneur
l'union rugby 178 recevait le rock jfo à
ce dimanche à montigny le bretonneux et
les événements réalisé une mauvaise
opération en s'inclinant 18 à 17
des images de nicolas d'andria montage
de julo grenet ville lui versé 78 rock j
fois le choc de milieu de tableau de
division honneur a tenu toutes ses
promesses
après une grosse bataille dans la
possession le stade roger couderc de
montigny le bretonneux a finalement vu
les visiteurs s'imposer dans les
derniers instants du match
ce qu'en finale à 18 à 17 h au c'est pas
compliqué ils ont fait un très beau
match
ils ont joué comme il fallait à
l'extérieur ils ont réussi à prendre le
score et derrière ils ont des bons
angles human qui ont bien joué et bien
bien géré bien gérer les temps forts
temps faibles et du coup bas à la fin ça
joue à rien mais c'est pour eux je pense
qu'on avait pas un mauvais match en
effet qu'on se crée les occasions pour
pour aller au bout il ya eu plein de
petites erreurs dans des zones de marque
qui nous coûte cher parce que l'arrivée
on aura un point alors qu'on aurait dû
beaucoup plus scoré pour pour faire moi
qui vaut deux équipes
donc effectivement on fait on fait une
belle prestation et on a failli passer à
la trappe à d'ailleurs la dernière
minute ces minutes de la fin quand même
donc mais on n'a pas perdu pied on est
allé jusqu'à la fête jusqu'au bout de la
concertation de la lucidité pour aller
rechercher les points qu'il fallait
malgré cette défaite lui verser 60 18
prend le point de bonus défensif les
saint quentinois se retrouve troisième
du championnat avec 23 points 5
victoires depuis le début de la saison
un bilan inattendue après huit journées
pour ce club issu d'une fusion entre le
sky rugby et montigny le bretonneux
il était très positif avant le match un
peu moins aujourd'hui
maintenant c'est une fusion aussi donc
un groupe est en train de se créer donc
c'est aussi des matches comme ça qui
nous permet de renforcer ce groupe
l'objectif jazz était sportif à la base
on se prend un petit peu au jeu
maintenant et finir dans les quatre
premiers
ça va être dur mais faut être ambitieux
prochain match pour lui verser 60 18 le
dimanche 8 décembre sur le terrain de la
nuit une équipe de bas de tableau de
division honneur
on continue par du football et le
championnat de régionale de trappes
jouer ce week-end contre ivry à domicile
et trappistes ont gagné 1 à 0 devant
leurs supporters cette troisième
victoire de la saison permet au joueur
dit chardy de reprendre espoir dans la
course à la montée
les trappistes son 9e sur 12 équipes
engagées prochain match contre
versailles pour le derby i vinoy le 15
décembre prochain toujours à domicile du
football toujours avec le championnat de
première division de district le chine
et s'incline 2 à 0 face à aubergenville
sartrouville s'impose sur le terrain du
pecq 3 2 hardricourt domine bois d'arcy
3 0 enfin à gargenville et où ils se
séparent sur le score de 1 but partout
à noter à le report des matches carrière
grésillons maurepas et voisins bailly
noisy le championnat est toujours dominé
par à gargenville handball dans le
championnat de nationale 3 plaisir s'est
imposé 28 à 26 à l'extérieur sur le
terrain d'asnières collomb veut cette
huitième journée pourrait être un
tournant dans la saison des yvelinois
avec cette victoire face à un concurrent
direct pour le maintien les plaisirs roy
pointe à la 9e place du championnat avec
trois victoires au compteur et s'éloigne
un peu plus de la zone de relégation
après le handball du basket dans le
championnat de nationale 3 9e journée
trappe s'est imposé 79 à 77 face à
fécamp poids sur son parquet de son côté
le chesnay versailles s'est imposée 74
56 à domicile au classement on retrouve
les deux équipes évinoise dans le top 5
le chesnay-versailles deuxième à un
petit point de la première place et
trappes pointe à la quatrième place du
classement la 10e journée est programmée
le week-end prochain
on passe maintenant à notre page jo de
on va parler des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024 le président du
comité d'organisation à tony estanguet a
annoncé la liste des 500 premières
collectivités à avoir décroché le label
terre de jeux 2024 parmi elles 14
entités yvelinoise on retrouve notamment
guyancourt plaisir et l'encours
poissy-saint-germain-en-laye ou encore
croissy-sur-seine et saint quentin en
yvelines pour nous parler de l'impact
d'un tel événement d'un tel label nous
recevons sur ce plateau à bernard débord
vice président en charge des sports à
saint quentin en yvelines
bonsoir bonsoir est très heureux d'être
là pour cette annonce effectivement
importante puisqu'on a trois communes du
territoire donc elancourt guyancourt et
plaisir qu'ils ont été retenus pour ce
label est parmi les deux communautés de
communes sur les yvelines on à saint
quentin en yvelines et c'était tout à
fait logique qu'on s'inscrive en fait
sur ce label étant donné qu'on a quand
même quatre sites olympiques sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
finalement ce n'était pas forcément une
surprise de voir saint quentin en
yvelines dans ses 500 premières
collectivités ce n'était pas une
surprise de nous voir candidate et
maintenant c'est un honneur de faire
partie des 500 premières qui ont été
annoncées donc au congrès des maires il
faut savoir que cette volonté c'est le
premier label au niveau des jeux
olympiques qui existera et qui existe en
fait qui est lancée et sur la volonté en
fête du cochon et paris 2024 souhaité à
travers ce label en fait faire des jeux
les jeux de tout le monde de tous les
citoyens
pas uniquement en fait des villes qui
vont accueillir donc des épreuves des
jeux olympiques mais de l'ensemble de la
population et donc à travers cela il ya
trois grands objectifs qui sont donc
souhaité par par le cojo à travers le
label un premier objectif qui en fait
ganisation je rappelle le cojo comité
d'organisation effectivement donc des
jeux olympiques qui a souhaité en fait
qu'on célèbre d'abord
les jo donc l'olympique et paralympiques
qu'on prépare aussi l'héritage des jeux
olympiques
l'héritage sur le plan sportif en
étrennant en fait le plus grand nombre
de citoyens à faire du sport c'est un
une opportunité pour nous de faire
découvrir des sports de créer de
l'engouement et surtout que les gens
après les jeux continuent à faire du
sport donc on va les entraîner jusqu'à
à travers un certain nombre de
manifestations en le faisant découvrir
des sportifs de haut niveau les faire
découvrir des sports qui ne pratiquent
pas aujourd'hui et puis petit à petit
l'enjeu c'est qu'il le pratique
eux-mêmes et puis enfin il ya
l'engagement qui est souhaitée de ces
villes qui ont demandé le label de paris
2004 quand vous avez fait pour décrocher
ce label c'était un dossier à monter
alors c'était un dossier à monter déjà
sur ce qu'on avait déjà fait puisque aux
50 et en yvelines et les communes donc
de saint-quentin que j'ai cités ont déjà
eu des actions pour la promotion faut
savoir que quand même saint quentin en
yvelines était candidat déjà sur paris
on a malheureusement la france n'a pas
été retenu on a mis en oeuvre un certain
nombre d'équipements je pense notamment
au vélodrome je prends ans au bmx et
puis on a mis en oeuvre en fait toute
une dynamique sportive avec les
fédérations la fédération de cyclisme
la fédération de golf avec la ryder cup
qui a été un grand succès donc ça c'est
déjà des choses qui ont été mises en
place on a déjà commencé en fait à
soutenir le sport de haut niveau et nos
champions soient en herbe soit déjà
confirmé en vue de préparer donc des
sportifs pour paris 2024 et donc là on
va continuer on va mettre le turbo il
est évident que là on a quatre années
devant nous pour faire explorer des deux
nouveaux champions et j'espère qu'on
aura en 2024 des médailles et saint
quentinois dernière question
concrètement qu'est-ce que ça va changer
ce label il y aura des têtes qui vont
venir s'entraîner sur saint quentin en
yvelines alors
bien évidemment le label va faire que en
fait le butin je le disais c'est
d'ouvrir les jeux olympiques à tout le
monde pas il faut pas que ça reste en
fait dans le microcosme des gens qui
sont déjà dans les clubs sportifs déjà
dans les associations déjà dans les
faits d il faut qu'on le fasse connaître
au grand public il faut qu'on le fasse
se connaître au niveau du scolaire en
2020 donc chaque année en fait vous avez
le 23 juin la journée jeux géo et le 23
juin donc 2020 je peux vous l'annoncer
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines
il y aura en fait une grande fête du
sport qui sera dédié notamment aux
scolaires où on veut faire découvrir un
certain nombre de sports et puis les
avoir l'occasion de rencontrer déjà des
sportifs médaillés d'avoir le petit et
des casques le petit
le petit plus ce qui fait qu'on a envie
d'y aller et puis on va le faire aussi
pour les associations
on va aussi dans le cadre de nos budgets
soutenir un certain nombre de
manifestations nationales et
internationales qui vont venir sur le
territoire de façon à donner à créer cet
engouement est à préparer 2024 merci
beaucoup merci d'être passé au plateau
on aura l'occasion de revenir
régulièrement sur l'organisation des jo
de 2024 ici sur ce plateau du 7-8 sport
pendant les cinq prochaines années un
mot de badminton à présent un tournoi
était organisé ce week-end à maurepas
par le club local ce rendez-vous a
regroupé plus d'une centaine de sportifs
venus des quatre coins de la france les
images de nicolas d'andré un montage de
xavier jeunes en les volant et les
raquettes étaient de sortie au gymnase
de l'âme elle me donne à maurepas un
tournoi de simple hommes et dames était
organisé par le club local ce samedi 30
novembre
un rendez vous qui a réuni des badistes
venus de toute la france on parle d'eux
du niveau le plus bas possible qu'ils
aient le p2 nc jusqu'à hier 4 5 il ya
déjà un très très bon niveau régional
c'est le plus haut niveau régional
ensuite nous n'avons pas ouvert cette
année au niveau national en terme de
classement doit dire n3 n2 n1 objectif
de cette journée pour les 120
participants présents répéter ses gammes
en vue des plus grosses échéances
prévues cette saison
le but était d'ajuster ses coûts au
millimètre manque de mobilité dans le
premier match et là c'est plus acheter
assez mobile mais j'étais sur le volant
et je faisais des fautes à mon niveau
c'est surtout pas faire de faute
les gestes simples en fait ne pas les
rater c'est surtout ça à notre niveau et
puis on a le match est et était bien
parti donc j'ai pu tester dès qu un peu
plus difficile mais il veut surtout pas
faire d'erreur pour se perfectionner les
joueurs disputent cinq à six parties au
maximum des matches de poules et des
matchs éliminatoires
tous les participants mettent en place
une stratégie personnelle pour aborder
ce tournoi chaque joueur va voir sa
propre stratégie entre guillemets il y
en a qui vont rentrer tête baissée dans
le tournoi dès le premier point et est
frappé fort et pour montrer qu'ils sont
présents et devons prendre le temps de
monter en puissance au fur et à mesure
que que le tournoi avance on reste
encore au niveau amateur on n'est pas
des professionnels du badminton loin de
là nous comprennent plaisir à jouer
si vous avez manqué ce tournoi deuxième
rendez-vous sera organisé par le club
les 18 et 19 avril prochains
cette fois ci les joueurs s'affronteront
en double les inscriptions s'ouvriront
dans les prochains jours on va
maintenant parler de sport automobile et
plus précisément de motocross elvis
gaulon jeunes sportifs de
montigny-le-bretonneux nés en 2008 et
passionné par cette discipline depuis
quelques années les connu une ascension
fulgurante avec notamment huit victoires
dans différentes ligues de france mais
également une place en équipe de france
nous avons la chance de le recevoir sur
ce plateau avec son père aurélien bon
soir alors on va tout d'abord revenir
sur ta passion qu'est ce qui t'a donné
envie de faire du motocross basse est
venu d'un coup oui bah y'a papa qui me
parler un petit peu parce qu'il en a
fait un peu quand il était jeune
avec papa on allait y avait une moto de
route et des fois j'étais derrière
et quand j'étais petit on a lu sur la
route et bah j'ai eu envie de faire ce
sport parce que j'allais ça allait ça
m'intéressait ça commence à kiel avec le
temps j'ai commencé à 8 ans 8 ans donc
il ya peu un finalement exactement aux
liens est-ce que c'est qu'il avait un
peu poussé où celui-ci s'est passé
commun mais en fait le sport mécanique
et plus particulièrement le motocross
c'est quand même une passion que j'aime
et que j'ai voulu retransmettre à elvis
il a tout de suite accroché donc à mon
plus grand bonheur
donc on passe les week-ends à
s'entraîner on est un petit peu partout
on voit du pays et il adore vraiment ça
alors on voit la moto qui est juste là
sur ce sur ce plateau explique nous
c'est quoi comme modèle 5
là bas ça va vite c'est préparer et
préparer sa valise
c'est à dire voilà bah la moto elle a de
la puissance qu'on acquiert elle a de la
chance c'est quand même beaucoup de
puissance 1 c
c'est petit mais costaud si la vie de
finalement c'est lui qui va vite
aurélien hisser la moto
la moto à vie mais il faut savoir
l'emmener également dans quelle vie
c'est là pour la piloter et c'est lui
qui met les gaz alors on l'a vu sur les
images c'est quand même assez
spectaculaire est-ce que c'est pas trop
dangereux quand on est un père de
famille est ce que c'est pas trop
dangereux de parité son fils à faire de
la moto cross alors c'est sûr qu'à
arriver un certain niveau il faut faire
attention il ya le stress qui est
toujours là en course puisqu'il ya quand
même des gros sauts plus ils prennent de
la bouteille plus ils vont vite plus il
vaut donc oui c'est quand même un sport
dangereux mais avec la technique
normalement on a tout se passe bien est
ce que tu as déjà eu des blessures oui
beaucoup
de quoi parlez-vous entorse au poignet
je suis caché le pousse tout à doit
bientôt à mieux alors on va revenir sur
l'aspect sportif tu as déjà à son actif
le disais précédemment huit victoires
dans différentes ligues de france de
participation au championnat de france
minivert une participation au
championnat d'europe emx euros 65
est-ce que tu t'attendais à voir ces
résultats là aussi rapidement je vous
rappelle ça fait que deux ans que c'est
la moto cross bah je m'attendais pas à
ça ça m'a surpris parce que l europe
quand je suis arrivé il y avait un très
gros niveau univers aussi et bah c'était
impressionnant et j'ai j'ai bien aimé
les deux pages que ya une belle ambiance
et voilà alors on tempère ce que vous
êtes surpris par ces résultats
bien sûr mais
on est toujours surpris mais après c'est
le fruit d'un très gros travail
puisqu'ils s'entraînent tous les
week-ends
avec l'équipe de france a notamment avec
l'équipe de france mais c'est surtout
moi qu'ils n'emmènent la plupart du
temps les week-ends donc on s'entraîne
énormément le week-end et on voit du
pays et pas forcément à
montigny-le-bretonneux
justement c est très peu en ile de
france en combustible le temps là le
week-end dernier on était haut on était
dans le nord à d'omar sur la mission que
c'est vers amiens le week-end prochain
on est à chinon le centre val de loire
donc on bouge tout le temps dès la
question quels sont tes objectifs pour
2020 j'aimerais home univers j'aimerais
faire top 5 et voir dans les trois
premiers mais faut bien s'entraîner
toute l'année et à l'europe
j'aimerais bien faire dans les dix frau
mais pour me qualifier pour la finale
je souhaite en tout cas bienvenue à tous
et de les passer sur ce plateau on vous
suivra avec attention sur les prochains
rendez vous dans ce statut ce set et
sport merci beaucoup merci avant on
prend maintenant la direction de plaisir
la semaine dernière la ville a organisé
sa semaine du handicap et le sport était
à l'honneur pour sensibiliser les
enfants sur cette thématique des
activités pour les primaires et les
collégiens étaient organisées au
programme basket fauteuil tennis de
table ou encore gymnastique handisport
avantage de grygera des ateliers pour se
glisser dans la peau d'un sportif en
situation de handicap pour la quatrième
année consécutive la ville de plaisir
organise au palais des sports ces
journées destinées aux enfants de la
commune scolarisés en primaire et au
collège
objectif sensibiliser la nouvelle
génération sur la situation de handicap
qu'ils puissent se projeter un petit peu
sûres
sur les différents types de handicaps
physiques pour le coup qu'on a et qu'on
va représenter sur cette semaine et que
les enfants puissent en parler autour
d'eux par la suite et se rendre compte
de l'importance des difficultés les
personnes handicapées on se mouvoir de
faire des activités mais aussi des
possibilités c'est pas parce que on se
retrouve en situation de handicap qu'on
ne peut plus rien faire
au programme notamment de cette journée
du tennis de table handisport les jeunes
ont pu tester la discipline avec un
bandeau sur les yeux ou sur des chaises
autres activités farid et le basket
fauteuil c'est assez compliqué déjà de
se diriger de faire des dribbles et de
marthe et surtout faucon-lambert réussir
parce qu'on est barque emmené dans un
fauteuil dont une pour tirer faut
s'entraîner on voit que c'est difficile
et qu'ils veulent quand même quand même
le faire au total près de 600 jeunes de
la ville participent à ces journées de
sensibilisation dans le cadre de la
semaine du handicap
une cinquième édition sera programmé
d'année prochaine une belle initiative
s'est déroulée à jeudi dernier au centre
pédiatrique des côtes des loges en josas
l'association sos gazelle a organisé une
après midi de noël avant l'heure à
destination d'une soixantaine d'enfants
malades
au programme un goûter et des cadeaux
une rencontre avec les anciens
footballeurs du psg patrick mboma et
amara simba
les enfants ont également pu assister à
un spectacle de clown on écoute les
différentes réactions micro de tv 78
nous essayons pour des enfants qui sont
en situation difficile soit démunie soit
en situation de problèmes de santé de
les soutenir de leur donner du bonheur
que leur donner de l'espoir et de la
joie et partager avec eux voilà des
moments
voilà les amuser et puis leur montrer
que voilà la vie c'est de l'espoir est
que aujourd'hui sont malades mais vont
s'en sortir et très bientôt ils seront
sur les terrains de sport quand on
rencontre les enfants et qu'on leur
donne
un petit moment c'est quelque chose de
particulier parce que petit on aimait
aussi ce genre d'attention c'est quelque
chose qui nous tient à coeur parce que
on sait que c'est arrivé à un gamin
c'était important
tout ce qui touche des enfants quand on
a besoin d'eux on répond présent
nous avons profité du passage de patrick
mboma dans les yvelines pour lui
demander s'il voulait a participé à
notre désormais traditionnel jeu à des
trois questions un incontournable de ce
sept huit sports et il n'a pas hésité
une seule seconde à se prêter au jeu
regardez
[Musique]
j'ai commencé le football parce que j'ai
une famille de footballeurs à faire
plusieurs football des grands ferries au
football et parce que je suis tombé
devant la coupe du monde 1978 intérêts
il y avait sept ans et demi et le virus
est arrivé à ce moment ce qui m'a plu
dans ce
dans cette féerie de la coupe du monde
c'est de voir des confettis l'argentine
était chez elle elle a gagné cette coupe
du monde il ya eu un héros mario kempès
qu'à marquer six buts meilleur buteur
meilleur joueur de cette coupe du monde
et je me suis dit à ce moment là il faut
un jour que j'ai une coupe du monde je
savais pas que voulez-vous dire devenir
footballeur professionnel
mais j'ai eu la chance de jouer et de
marquer dans deux coupes du monde c'est
plus qu'un rêve qui est devenu réalité
mon meilleur souvenir dans le football
c'est la victoire en 2000 aux jeux
olympiques de sydney c'est la première
fois que le cam on avait une médaille de
de surcroît elle était en or et je me
souviens avoir entonné n'a crié l'hymne
national du cameroun c'était une joie
immense avec un retour au pays qui a été
exceptionnel ça c'est bien fêté ça a
pris beaucoup de temps ça on n'a pas
beaucoup dormi
on a pris un peu de poids parce qu'on a
mangé un peu tout et n'importe quoi mais
en tout cas on a donné de la joie à 25
millions de personnes et ça c'est
quelque chose d'un commencera
mon avis on ne sait pas de quoi il est
pas ce que je fais maintenant c'est que
je commente des matches depuis huit ans
avec canal+ afrique j'ai une fonction au
sein de l'international football
association board qui régit et revoit
les les lois vive du football g
fondation de défenses de l'éléphant et
de l'environnement règle générale et
puis que dire je suis un sur père de
cinq enfants une découverte dans ce
magazine gardien de but un poste clé
dans une équipe de football fabien
barthez john nugée bouffonne iker
casillas ou plus pressé récemment manuel
neuer tous ont marqué en son nom marqué
leur rôle et ont été décisifs dans la
victoire finale de leur équipe mais seul
un goal dans l'histoire a été auréolé du
ballon d'or le soviétique lev yachine en
1963 et mignoni micha pour vous grégory
canal et bonsoir bonsoir
alors expliquez nous un petit peu ce que
vous avez fait c'est totalement une
ignominie pour moi que seul un gardien
dans l'histoire et était récompensé du
ballon d'or voilà je me changeais en
militant ce soir mon poste gardien de
but un poste trop souvent négligé un
exemple connu de tous
vous en avez fait peut-être l'amère
expérience dans les cours de récré
personne ne voulait aller au but mickaël
pire que ça on y mettait même un joueur
le moins doué avec alex et pied j'ai
voulu rétablir la vérité
gardiens c'est un rôle difficile qui ne
laisse pas de place au hasard et ça
nécessite un entraînement spécifique
très physique regardez c'est un poste
que j'occupe depuis mes 6 ans gardien de
but un rôle passion un rôle méconnu et
souvent décrié on a tendance souvent à
incriminer le gardien de but quand
l'équipe subit est justement un but
alors je vais vous montrer que c'est pas
si facile que ça d'occuper ce poste et
je vais vous le montrez ce soir avec les
gardiens de l'étoile sportive de trappes
l'équipe fanion évolue en régionale 2
c'est le deuxième plus haut niveau
régional et suivez moi c'est parti
et donc je suis avec loïc qui est
entraîneur de gardiens à l'étoile
sportive de trappes
bonsoir loïc le poste de gardien de but
juste si on fait une petite introduction
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est un
sport individuel à l'intérieur d'un
sport collectif est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette présente tout avec
lui tout à fait d'accord avec vous c'est
un sport individuel pour un gardien
puisqu'il est tout seul sur le terrain
il est presque considéré comme un
individu à part dans l'équipe même s'il
peut avoir un rôle de vice capitaine
puisqu'il a le droit à la parole super
c'est un rôle qui a évolué en gaule pas
aujourd'hui comme angolais il ya 20 à 25
ans quels sont les trois qualités
si à trois qualités d'adressé pour un
gardien de but quelles sont elles la
première c'est la qualité mentale faut
très solide dans sa tête
la deuxième je dirais que
il faut avoir une capacité à entraîner
les autres et a commandé comme un
capitaine puisque faut savoir travailler
sur une défense
la troisième je dirais que c'est la
négation là je vais pouvoir m'entraîner
avec le gardien de l'équipe une senior
quels sont les exercices qu'on va faire
ce soir pour un gardien de but les
exercices c'est toujours la répétition
aux prises de balle coordination travail
au sol
c'est toujours à peu près le même
travail puisque c'est toujours les mêmes
choses qui se reproduit sur le terrain
et il faut les revoir en permanence
allez je vais aller rejoindre tout de
suite l'entraînement des gardiens
[Musique]
j'avais beaucoup parce que c'est
physique
[Musique]
je suis avec le gardien de l'équipe
seniors l'équipe i seniors qui évoluent
en régionale 2 déjà qu'est ce qui t'a
donné toi envie de faire ce poste le
poste de gardien de but moi en tout
franchement en fait j'aurais bien voulu
jouer en attaque
en fait j'étais très très doué côté
gardien de but
à l'époque dans les quartiers un bain en
afrique notamment
j'ai joué au goal dès l'âge de 8 9 ans
petit dernière question sur
l'entraînement convient de faire est ce
que c'est important pour toi de les
faire pour te préparer au mieux pour les
dimanches et est-ce que tu trouve ça
difficile du coup ouais spécifique ça
reste toujours difficile
en même temps si c'est le bon moyen
aussi pour être toujours en forme donc
qui verront le temps en forme doit
forcément passer par sa donc la raison
pour laquelle je travaille pour être au
top tôt dimanche
merci on va te laisser travailler et
j'espère que voilà je vous ai donné
envie en tout cas de découvrir ce poste
que voilà qui me passionne que j'occupe
depuis mai et mes 6 ans aller au travail
sur les terrains et je n'ai pas pu m'en
empêcher michael j'ai testé le gardien
de l'équipe une senior de trappes
moi je vais tester tout de suite mamadou
sur un petit défi frappe j'espère lui m
allez on va miser sur deux buts c'est
déjà quelque chose c'est parti
[Musique]
la vie
j'étais un petit déçu mais on a mis deux
donc jamais trois or et les red bull
[Musique]
route
entente
on
non
[Musique]
champion mais c'est vrai qu'il a tiré
centrale il a été sympa avec moi en tout
cas la merci de nous avoir accueillis et
on espère vraiment qu on vous a donné
envie de d'occuper ce poste de gardien
de but
si vous l'avez compris et très cher pour
nous saluer merci beaucoup grégory c'est
déjà la fin de 7,8 sport merci d'avoir
suivi très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]